ils sont 226 226 à prétendre à un poste
de conseiller départemental des yvelines
l'élection se déroulera les 22 et 29
mars
chaque électeur de chacun des 21 cantons
votre en réalité pour un binôme hommes
femmes la droite déjà largement
majoritaire entend rester premier parti
des yvelines et a donc sceller son
alliance avec les centristes de l'udf
pendant que la gauche part divisée que
le front national entend jouer les
trouble fête en se présentant
c'est une première dans toute les
yvelines dans le détail sur le secteur
de saint quentin on retrouve sur le
canton de montigny le bretonneux le
président de l'agglomération michel
laugier divers droite
associé à laurence trochut de l'ump le
sortant socialiste françois de ligne et
maire de guyancourt fait alliance avec
la responsable départementale du ps
sandrine grand gang
un duel qui sera particulièrement suivie
l'absence d'union à gauche avec une
liste europe écologie les verts front de
gauche sera peut-être déterminant la
droite entend réaliser le grand chelem
sur ces élections de l'aveu du président
sortant pierre bédier et pour cela elle
n'hésite pas à envoyer des élus de
premier plan
ainsi jean michel fourgous maire ump
d'elancourt et anne capio sa deuxième
adjointe vont tenter de ravir le canton
de trappes à jeanine marie divers gauche
et alain ajaj mais un communiste de la
verrière qui lui n'a pas reçu le soutien
de son parti qui préfèrent l'alliance
avec europe ecologie les verts
candidature surprise celle du directeur
du collège musulman de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines stemann busan
à un cas atypique sur le canton de
maurepas ce sont deux conseillers
sortants qui se font face en raison du
redécoupage imposées par l'état ismaila
vannes ps face à yves vandewalle ump
chacun avec son binôme christine merci
adjointe à magny les hameaux et
alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux là aussi fortes
divisions à gauche entre l'alliance
écologiste communiste et la présence du
candidat malheureux aux dernières
municipales à maurepas michel chat pas
sûr plaisir à présent division des
écologistes et des communistes présence
du front national présence de debout la
france et rivalités ump ps
pas moins de six listes l'élu
départemental sortant le socialiste jean
michel gourdon a décidé de ne pas se
représenter
enfin sur le canton de saint ciers à
l'école jean philippe mallet brigue un
nouveau mandat avec la socialiste
fabienne jargon bilbo mais après avoir
remporté la mairie de bois d'arcy l'ump
philippe benassaya aimerait renforcer
son implantation sur le secteur avec
l'aide de l'ue dit sonia bros
ces listes de candidats restent
néanmoins provisoire le ministère de
l'intérieur doit encore se prononcer sur
leur validité